billion dollars what are you doing for a
billion dollars I'll tell you what I got
a billion dollars each one of you guys
are for sure getting hooked up with ten
thousand they're so generous [ __ ]
homie dude she's being [ __ ] sarcastic
you Pricks no seriously that's nice
after all I've done for you I'm happy
for the crumb thank you very much
[Music]
so Joe what's up dog dude
everybody work for JK except for you all
right
except for you and Bart we all chip in
we're like hey dude let's [ __ ] buy
lotto ticket we all chip in right and
then we all win with that lotto ticket
everybody's a [ __ ] millionaire
dude that's a thing I'll be like how
come you didn't tell me I would have put
money in too and we tried that before at
JK we did a whole Lottery together and
then we were already thinking we were
gonna win and we already thinking what
we're gonna buy because we lost that's a
beautiful thing all of us win except for
you and Bart which also mean that like
we don't really have to come to work
anymore you know
um
how would you feel would you be like a
support would you be like nah dude you
got to come to work I feel like why
don't you guys invite me to the lotto
first of all about that hurt out of
everybody in this room you know I
probably gamble the most with you you
got a bet against us though you know
what I'm saying the second thing is that
already happened and that was crypto
baby and I'm glad it crashed because
that's why you're still here damn
[Laughter]
no I I think to me this was especially
if it was other businesses is different
because it's for the money but this has
never been about that so that would hurt
that would be that would feel like a
personal attack if it was any other
business then I'd be like I get it dude
like you don't have to be here like all
the Jimmy people
anything yeah if I was a part of the
crew and I got that money I am how do
you do yeah I'm out dude I would be like
that [ __ ] stop my [ __ ] money down
watch when you have history to me I'm
not gonna I'm gonna you're gonna you're
not gonna wanna leave me you're right
you know what I mean we need history I
feel like I want to be the snitch for
you like hey dude like let everybody at
least those guys are talking [ __ ] about
you dude you're the best all right call
me your hair your long-ass hair don't
call me your long-ass hair
you're the best and this was just like
you think so I mean I just think it's so
much you know JK news is so much weight
on my shirt you're hurt the [ __ ]
funniest dude all right they're always
walking over your lines all right one of
them tells long-ass [ __ ] stories that
go nowhere
anyone stays in this computer chatting
to people he's got Facebook on actually
he's not even he's not Facebook
Messenger bro
he's the true homie you know so that's
where we went that actually happened it
to a mining boss in Australia all the
workers and they bounced not yet not yet
20 20 of his best employees did win the
Mega Mega good for them
yeah they deserve it they do yeah dude
that's like yeah that's hard [ __ ]
work man each of his employees basically
of the 20 of the best ones got over two
million dollars the boss who works in a
West Australian mining town of uh
Calgary Calgary Cal what a yeah admits
that uh you know he was totally in
disbelief he was just like no no way
they're like we won the lottery he's
like no [ __ ] way trust me you did not
[ __ ] did you win the lotto it was like
that right and then after they're like
yeah we won blah blah blah the next day
he's like hey you guys are still coming
to work
that's very hard to get Replacements
yeah nobody wants to work hard in the
mind bro oh my God and the idea for all
of them still mines at the same time
same time yeah by the way there's still
mines out here what are we still using
gold for what the [ __ ] I think the
hardest part would be the transition
like I'd understand it if I was the
mining company owner it's like dude you
gotta you gotta get yours but please
train somebody to take care please don't
please don't leave it the exact same
time right but please at least stay like
stagger your leave or like train people
in the middle like in Australia go to
Mexico I swear to God you'll come back
with a bunch of people who are willing
to [ __ ] it up all right give them the
good ass money yeah dude that is gnarly
though that's crazy but then they were
honorable enough to split it with each
other right right that's what I was
gonna say they're really like all of
them 20 people all walked away with over
like 2.5 million dollars that's tight
after taxes no I think they have to pay
taxes yeah yeah let me see okay well so
that's still nice 1.3 dude that's
[ __ ] let's see that was a total of 34
million dollars divide that by 20.
see 34. I don't know that you guys do
math here dude I just left the wood like
damn that's a shitload yo got a
calculator for a reason oh he does NERD
oh it's actually 1.7 million each so
let's say they got a million after taxes
but it's Australian dollars it's weaker
it's weaker but yeah 1.7 that's what I
need baby that's all I need even a
million a million after tax get a bill
I'm good and I'm a miner that's great
that's a whole other lifestyle if you
win Jesus if you win the lotto would you
still do stand up
yeah dude stand up because Santa it's
like
I don't do it for money I'll tell you
that much these are paying me instead of
it's like it's definitely out for money
I'd stand up is just like a therapy
thing it's like I just love it I can't
live without it like it's the only thing
that's like I can do yeah that's what
this is for me yeah I'm like whether I'm
broke or Rich this is fun this is just
yeah this is like [ __ ] but what would I
do with that money I'll do some crazy
[ __ ] I'll do some crazy [ __ ] I was like
[ __ ] Wolf of Wall Street [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying with a million
you'll last one day then if you're doing
no if I want if I want the freaking uh
the big one the billion dollar one yeah
I know that's what you were talking
about whatever the Powerball no I would
have been like you know
nowadays you can't really do [ __ ] with
the meal you could buy half a house in
L.A give me a million then
no but you can't even like buy a house
in L.A a half of a house you can buy a
condo nice little downtown you can buy a
condo cool little couch or just called
orange second couch on Burger's house
yeah in L.A you can't a million dollars
you could get a house in Pomona hi yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] meth neighbors
but I will while out for sure you want
to wall out I would for sure while out
yeah off of I'll be talking one million
we're talking one billion one million do
both yeah yeah one for each yeah one
million is like you're already worried
about like it being gone so it's like
all investment yeah yes but at one
billion while out like wow I have to do
it everything is considered what's your
investment though you're going back to
crypto nah wait wait wait is that the
truth that you did crypto and absolutely
foreign
[Laughter]
like like I take you guys to Del Taco
and rent out the whole restaurant and be
like yo anything you want it's on me I
think Julia would just buy her own
Mountain yeah so she could hike on it
yeah but it's like a hill yeah dude the
Del Taco thing I've done that in a drunk
night that's not that's not impressive
like I've done whatever you guys want
dude
but see that's what I mean with the
million you can still do that yeah you
know you can feel it do that with a
million sure my producer is also a fan
of Del Taco oh cool so you are now alone
in the Del Taco train that I can go to
Del Taco with your producer we could
ball out yeah
yeah I love to go to high school you're
asking for it dude yeah no I love it
dude I don't care I'll take it yeah what
about you Nick million bucks I think I
still work bro I'd for sure still work
yeah I mean I'd just buy a house for
sure I'll still work that's it yeah I
feel like a million dollars really don't
get you too far so you're only thinking
about practical [ __ ] we got to jump
straight to like at least half a billion
at least just a straight let's go
billion billion dollars what are you
doing for a billion dollars I'll tell
you what I got a billion dollars each
one of you guys are for sure getting
hooked up with 10 000. you're so
generous
you Pricks no seriously that's nice
no seriously I wish I wish crypto comes
back because I would I would love that
dude I would love for you because you
don't have to give the money to anybody
so I'm just happy that you're willing to
you're thinking of us that's very
appreciative yeah after all I've done
for you I'm happy for the crumb thank
you very much
the crumb I would buy an island
but I would definitely get an island for
sure where
you know that's a good question uh you
want a Cold Island like in Canada or do
you want a tropical island you know
what's funny I've never I didn't even
know there's a difference right now so I
got an iceberg I don't know there was a
difference but it was it's Hawaii a cold
island or a hot Island it's tropical
it's hot so it's hot yeah it's warm this
is why I should have learned this in
school but you're from Arizona I was
trying to figure it's like near the
equator what are you doing we're
learning about islands and [ __ ]
coldness [ __ ] that what are you doing
what's up well I'm down there but uh
yeah I would definitely get tropical
island tropical island and I'll just
live there and just [ __ ] Live It Up
just live it up Pina Coladas walk around
Nate it's a nudist beach for me and I'm
gonna do whatever I want I like Kona
coconuts that's pretty good I want a
coconut Farm what would you guys do with
it you didn't say anything yeah what
would you do Colleen I would I would
travel the world at like the bougiest
level that's what I said bro control the
world
the world at the bougiest level really
no you start a bank huh
[Laughter]
I give you guys all student loans yeah
you guys
I feel like she want to finance like
super cool things I would invest yeah
absolutely but I would definitely travel
I would prioritize that where's your
dream place to travel oh there's a bunch
of places pick one uh Japan would you
like she pointed at Joe I like Japan
like I would go to Japan I would go to
Japan
if it wasn't for Cove oh yeah I think
they just no they're fully open now oh
yeah yeah it's actually better because
now the Dollar's way stronger so it's
cheaper to go yeah good for us bad for
them I know right for us
I can't do I want to do an Asian country
I just don't know which one Thailand
Greece
um all over Europe that sounds good well
you said Iceland that was fire Iceland
yeah I want to do Iceland I'll be honest
though I don't know if I could do it
just because of the flights dude that's
the only thing I can't do I can't do a
flight more than three hours just start
like you're balling up hey but first
first class though launches
money yeah bruh just go three hours a
time yeah I know I hated a little stop
no but you're a billionaire so you could
have a jet you're right that's first
first class
[ __ ] us right [ __ ] me in my [ __ ]
private jet idea damn dude
his biggest one I'm going to Iceland
baby yeah [ __ ] yeah dude or you could
rent a canoe
[Music]
laughs
foreign